Phil?
James. What's up?
I sold this cool cat, a house in the hills
last year. Since then, his bluegrass band
has really taken off. It's so crazy.
We started doing it ironically, and before
we knew it, we were actually doing it for
real.
That happened to me in the 90s.
Was saying, exsqueeze me.
Yeah, well, I assume from your tour of the
ancient costume and your pale slave out of
costume that you guys are here to see
Defenders of Infinity.
Oh, yeah. It is so incredible.
Really? Yeah.
Hey, if you really want to be blown away,
I've got two special gummy bears.
You can have just one for each of us.
Believe me, one is all you need.
I guess we can get more of the concession
stand. No, they.
Don't sell gummy bears like these here.
Oh, you get extra cool ones from Europe or
something.
Guys, how are you not getting this?
It's pot. Oh, I don't know why, but I've
never tried marijuana.
No, no. Me neither.
There was always something stopping, me
needing to take care of Lily.
The figure skating honor code, not wanting
to accidentally tell everyone in high school
I was gay.
People never offered it to me.
Which is weird, because in college, I was
kind of a big man on campus.
I founded a major organization, the National
Association of Responsible Cheerleaders.
Narcs. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay.
Here. They take 45 minutes to hit.
So take them now and you'll be good to go
when the movie starts.
I. I'm, you know, if we ever were going to
try this. Tonight's kind of the perfect
opportunity. I guess
you're right. No kids.
I'm wearing velcro sneakers.
Should we?
I've always wanted to know what it'd be
like. Plus, I went to the gym today.
I deserve a sweet.
Let's do it. Okay.
I'm shaking. Thank you.
Cheersies.
Chew smaller. Sup?
Oh, I cannot believe we're doing this.
This is so exciting.
Oh! Oh, God. I knew this was a horrible
mistake. I just got
an alert our smoke alarm went off.
It's not coming up.
Okay, okay.
Relax. Okay. I'm gonna call Luke, find out
what's up. Yeah. Voicemail.
This rap's hilarious, though.
Call Claire.
She's not home. We're going to have to check
this out.
No. Come on. Those alerts are always nothing.
Plus.
Our crime. Listen, we have assigned seats and
45 minutes till this kicks in.
That gives us plenty of time to Uber home,
make sure everything's fine, touch up my
veins and get back. I'll set an alarm so we
know exactly when it hits.
No. You're right. Lily's there. Yes, yes.
Let's go.
Plus, we're not going to want to deal with
this when we're high and paranoid.
Oh, God. Do you think the paranoia will be
bad?
Is everything okay?
Yes. It was just a false alarm.
Well, then we should
probably get back to the theater.
Those pre-movie trivia questions aren't
going to answer themselves, are they?
Actually they do.
Wait a minute.
What the hell is going on here, huh?
Yep. I smell cheap beer.
Someone's been having a party.
Claire, you're just being crazy.
Take a look around.
Nothing is going on.
There is no party.
Everyone just be cool.
Okay?
No one's here.
Is that your watch alarm?
We have to get out of here.
I do not want to be high in front of Claire.
Wait.
I think I'm feeling something.
Oh, no.
What are you feeling?
Nice.
Oh, God.
Are you feeling anything?
No.
And why are you leaning like that?
I'm not leaning.
Maybe you're leaning so it looks like I'm
leaning.
Oh, yeah. You're right.
Phil, what are you doing?
Still searching.
Anything suspicious?
Say nothing. Okay.
Phil.
Answer her. You said say nothing.
I meant say the word. Nothing.
Word.
Nothing.
That was so good.
Thanks, man.
Okay, Philip, focus.
We have got to finish searching this house
before we start acting weird or.
Nothing.
That was so great.
Learned from the best.